ah welcome to this video that's a good
opponent here Grandmaster Seward italic
very good player Vatican cydia another
joke yeah that's a really strong player
from Turkey on check we like it's just
very ambitious chest that he plays and
also has very good annotations of his
own games when he publishes this 93-86
we might just pose playing this more
interesting I was I want to save my
transpose into some new mizzou Indian
structure where I've played a five which
is sometimes debatable the merits of
this move okay it's still a fairly
normal structure be six or not
or should I play with e 5 always a bit
unsure about that but I'm going 45 but
sure if I should have played h6 if I
want to play with you five but ok you
have to yeah sometimes you just have to
make a move here ok so maybe rookie aid
take on d4 now he takes Bishop c3 bc
I don't like it that much here she
threatening to ever trap my bishop can
kill me possible
it's also 95 here a5 is kind of useless
in this position or even sometimes yeah
a little bit to my disadvantage I don't
know if I played this too well one good
thing about blacks position is it is
still relatively solid young you cannot
I mean white will probably not be able
to kill me quickly or anything but it
looks it looks quite nice for wider I
definitely would like to have YTM Bishop
to g3 preventing 92 g six and that's f4
I am as a possible continuation
very awkward very awkward pinya that I'm
them in here I wonder ever should play
g5 some time but then therefore I gets
much stronger even mm-hm awkward just an
awkward position a voice is really
coming
queeny's happen is also not really good
yeah but what what exactly should i do
have three a simple simple and good
approach
preventing a forum yeah I don't know I
really have no no good plan him
now I kind of confused the move on a
probably somewhere
yeah he finally went for this yeah I
cannot have to take I know that he will
he's able to take on f6 now but I'm
hoping that this is not that terrible at
least the opening of the e-file lets me
trade some stuff and I was thinking here
and then but he has Bishop have two
years
I want it's kind of embarrassing
wow great I cannot even Quincy five
Bishop of to Queen a three-night be one
who wow wow that was really really bad
time morning yeah I know what the what a
bad game him check I mean it's not a bad
game per se but he pleaded terribly
looking like a complete idiot here in
this game oh damn Megan you can take
with the queen is the best of the
problem yeah that's the problem I of
course I saw it as well but what can I
do other moves i have f 52 black resides
cheb this is this wasn't this wasn't any
any success IAM let me think about this
what exactly did I do wrong here well
these things is okay and now he
immediately went there sorry yeah maybe
if maybe in this structure I shouldn't
play this this this 5 and it's it's
sometimes it's sometimes it's very
delicate thing to handle the porn
structures in this positions it's maybe
maybe it's a better to to just play b6
hear something like this we should be
seven castles and hereafter you castles
I probably should take because there are
ideas to retreat the bishop and here's
interesting you can take with the Queen
Oh at the pawn it takes with the Queen
there is this idea
with simplifications no I don't know
should be it should be okay the
weakening on the King side is probably
not so important one idea or you can
take with the pawn and here yeah maybe
something like this is an idea trying to
take here King g7 maybe later if he goes
efore i have e 5 i've been probably
better than the game I don't know which
probably isn't that super terrible as
well but I have to be more precise
that's clear yeah maybe maybe taking on
z3m my original intention was to take
here and then take but it's just it's
just not good yeah maybe I can Jim this
pin is always awkward it's always
awkward yeah activating I was always
shying away from g5 maybe this is what I
must do we have something like this and
deform something like this but yes FY
it's not it's simply not a good position
f3 this is not helping yeah I know I
know I have to play you for I guess yeah
I was I was relying on this on this on
this trades on the if I wear this is
simply simply catching Mike we jam this
is kind of embarrassing yeah I played it
badly he played it well so I hope she'll
be up you're like that thanks for
watching